wrapping up this series with the indians
with lance mccullers jr on the hill
there he is 15 starts this season well
below three with that era at 2.80 the
opponent batting average is a ridiculous
188 he has done a very good job against
right-handed hitters holding them to a
177 batting average
here comes the 2-2 to rosario swing and
a miss
there is that slider that's been such a
big weapon for him this year picking up
the first strikeout of the night with a
slider he's really starting to find the
command and the release point of that
slider on our mattress firm super mow we
try and slow it down so you get a better
visual of what is going on but that is a
pitch that is breaking
and it's breaking late and fooling a lot
of right-handed hitters
swinging him as he gets reyes on another
slider
two strikeouts in the inning for
mccullers and the astros will bat in the
bottom half of the first after the
indians failed the top half
eli morgan is going to be the indian
starting pitcher making his seventh
start a 1-3 record 786 era
3-2 there's a fastball and he pumped it
by him
at the top of the zone for route number
one well he didn't back off he went
there it had a good part of the plate
but
el tube laid off a couple high fastballs
in that ad bat but he doesn't on this
one
that one i don't think was a strike but
that's the time three two he went after
it
morgan gets the strikeout julie guriel
stands in
got him foul tip struck him out and what
a first inning for eli morgan
they go one two three here's oscar
mercado
swing and a miss lance picks up yet
another strikeout with a slider that's
three for three in strikeouts tonight
seven of his 10 strikeouts last start
against chicago was on the slide
yeah it's interesting watching it from
behind we can see where that pitch
starts and where it ends up so it looks
so good on that inner third
as it comes across the plate you can see
mercado's hips
kind of opening up trying to cover the
inside but can't stay on the outside
three strikeouts of the first five outs
tonight for lance 2-2
swing and a miss got a fastball by him
upstairs perez down on strikes
the colors has 4ks and it's a 1-2-3
inning
cesar hernandez hit by a pitch his first
time up it's two balls of two strikes
mccullar is ready here's the pitch
it's a change-up squid and it's a fair
ball down the third base line
right over the bag and down the line now
scoring his chang
zimmer to third base it's one nothing on
the q
shot by cesar hernandez yeah that's just
really tough luck right there
right along the line and then hit off
third base
and trickles kind of in the in the no
man's land
neither toro nor brantley was going to
be able to get over there quick enough
to prevent chang from scoring especially
with two out
ends up being an rbi double for
hernandez and two men in scoring
position now
one nothing lead for the cleveland pitch
inning would like to be efficient here
in the fourth and maybe into the fifth
to get deeper into this game
in the center field long run for miles
straw slicing away from him
kyle tucker comes out of nowhere
straw the corner of his eye saw tucker
and he bailed out and let tucker made a
deciding catch that was
danger written all over it it's not too
often you have the opportunity to show
up and see
synchronized outfielding but that was a
pretty good effort between
miles straw and kyle tucker and i love
the fact that they were able to go
underneath and over the top but a great
that's just that
sixth sense that you have on the field
when you know you're getting close to
another player because like you said
that was a very long run
bottom of the fourth inning indians lead
one nothing here's altuve of course the
astros lead off batter it's nine up nine
down so far against eli morgan
as altuve drives one deep to left field
alturve
three home runs in two games it's one
allen into the crawford boxes to tie the
game at one
number 23 on the year for altuve and
jose altuve in full extension going to
get that you can see that left foot
almost stepping on the plate
to go out and get around this fastball
and hit a line drive into those crawford
boxes
[Applause]
and we're tied one out of nobody on for
kyle tucker grounded out his first
time tucker hooks one deep to right
field that ball
is good home run kyle tucker
home runs in back-to-back games like
altuve
and the astros lead 2-1 on a couple of
solo home runs tucker's
17th of the year pretty impressive to
stay back on that changeup
eli morgan has a very good change up and
it seems to take about a half an hour to
get to the plate so as a hitter you've
really got to stay
disciplined and stay on that keep the
hands back and that's exactly what kyle
tucker did you kind of lose that lower
half but he's strong enough to stay on
this pitch down and yank it
just over that right field fence hit it
right up that tunnel in right field
tucker homers for a second straight day
his 17th homer of the season
and just like that the astros take the
lead astros lead 2-1
bases are loaded with indians and nobody
out roberto perez will be the batter and
brian of riyu the new pitcher
big situation for abreu out of that
bullpen dusty calling his number
swaying and a miss big strikeout for
brian abreu out of the bullpen
first out of the inning and a strikeout
to start his out
now you chang will bat he singled scored
a run and also struck out
swinging a miss abreu back-to-back
strikeout
staying with the slider he gets perez
and chang
and now two outs and the base is still
loaded big back-to-back strikeouts for
brian abreu
see what he does here with ernie clement
got a fly ball
[Applause]
off the wall two runs will score here
comes the third
the throw to the play say it's a
three-run double
for ernie clement a two-out
dagger for the tribe as they come back
in
regain the lead in houston my goodness
he
ended up jumping on that first pitch
getting a breaking ball and what a big
hit for ernie
he got abreu got the first two
strikeouts first pitch here he says i'm
not waiting
for it he got after it plugged a gap
what a nice job two out hitting right
there clears the bases the indians on
top
and oh for that two out hit
otto easily ahead of the throw and gets
a high five from the big man
friend mill riff an opportunity here
with a big swing to either tie it up
or get the astros back in this thing now
tuvek drills one deep to left field
looking up and it's off the wall
maldonado a great jump he'll score
easily
altuve heads to second base sliding with
an rbi double
it's a one run game now four to three
is continuing to fight in this game
nicely done by jose altuve as he trades
places with martine maldonado
nearly a triple a home run and a sac fly
his career against shaw this one up the
middle that'll tie the game up
eely down to the count doesn't matter
rbi base hit we're tied at four
beautifully done by an rbi machine i'll
count one out nobody on
here's the pitch there's a high fly ball
did he get it you bet he did get out of
here it's gone a home run
and the indians go back in front number
16 for cesar hernandez that's a new
career high
in home runs and the indians are back in
front
five four heading to the bottom of the
ninth inning the astros down one
tucker a home run and three at bats none
of the astros who have batted in this
inning have faced
karinchik before
[Applause]
the moving target roberto looked like he
was waving to him
wave goodbye book it the indians get the
win here in houston to salvage the
finale
and they finished the road trip three
and three coming out of the all-star
break
it was a hard earned victory here
tonight in houston as the indians win it
by a final of 5-4